In the previous video we have seen how atomic
mass is measured.
Now let us
understand atomic mass in detail.
Before that, can you tell me what exactly
the concept of Atomic Number is?
Can you define it once for me?
Yes!
It is simply the number of protons present
inside the nucleus of an atom.
Now on similar lines, can you tell me what
atomic mass could be?
Yes!
It simply means the mass of an atom.
But how will we determine it?
Imagine we have a bag which is made up of
extremely thin material.
So thin
that it almost does not have any mass of its
own.
Now we fill this bag with
some stuff inside.
If this bag is placed on a weighing scale,
then can we say that
the total mass of the bag will be the sum
of mass of all the objects inside it?
Absolutely!
Similarly, the mass of an atom can be calculated
with the help of the subatomic
particles in it.
But we know that among all the subatomic particles
electrons have negligible
mass.
That is they are considered to be almost weightless!
So what are we left with?
Yes!
We have both: protons and neutrons in the
nucleus.
And these two do have some amount of mass
is what we know.
Now tell me one thing, which among these two
particles should be
considered?
Shall we consider only the mass of protons
or only the neutrons?
Or both together?
Well, since both have a significant amount
of mass, we will
consider the mass of both together!
Thus, atomic mass is defined as the total
number of protons and neutrons
present inside the nucleus of the atom.
It is also referred to as the mass
number!
Let us take a simple example.
In case of a simple element like Fluorine,
we find that there are nine protons
and ten neutrons in the nucleus.
Wait a second… we have always come across
cases where the atomic nucleus
has an equal number of protons and neutrons.
So how is it that the number of
neutrons is more?
Well, tell me, does the presence of additional
neutrons
really bother the atom?
Does the charge of the atom increase or decrease?
Absolutely not!
That’s because they’re neutral.
Then why should an extra
neutron bother us?
So coming back to the atomic mass of Fluorine,
we have nine protons and ten
neutrons.
That means the total would give us nineteen!
So can we say that the
atomic mass of Fluorine is nineteen units?
Yes!
Just like Fluorine, even Aluminium has an
extra neutron compared to the
number of protons.
That is, in a single atom of aluminium, we
have thirteen protons and fourteen
neutrons.
Summing up the two we get twenty seven units
which is the atomic
mass of Aluminium.
Now let’s take another random example of
Chlorine!
A chlorine atom has seventeen protons and
eighteen neutrons.
That means the
atomic mass of chlorine will be thirty five
units.
Right?
Absolutely!
But wait a
second… a few chlorine atoms that exist
in nature exhibit a different form.
)
Some of them have seventeen protons and twenty
neutrons!
That gives us the
atomic mass of chlorine as thirty seven units!
So which one is the correct atomic mass?
In case of chlorine, both the atomic
masses are right.
The atoms having seventeen protons and eighteen
neutrons
have an atomic mass of thirty five units.
On the other hand, chlorine atoms
with seventeen protons and twenty neutrons
have an atomic mass of thirty
seven units.
But now the next question to pop up in our
minds is “How can we have one
element having two different kinds of atoms?”And
is this valid only for chlorine
or are there other elements also which exhibit
this phenomenon?
Let us find out more about this mysterious
concept of Isotopes in the next
video!